nous poursuivons donc ce soir nos
travaux sur le projet de loi de finances
pour 2023 avec l'examen des crédits de
la mission santé qui sont à l'ordre du
jour de la séance du 3 novembre je
rappelle donc ce que j'avais dit tout à
l'heure je donnerai d'abord la parole à
la ministre pour une dizaine de minutes
puis à notre rapporteur Christophe Benz
que je salue pour 10 minutes également
viendront ensuite les orateurs des
groupes politiques pour 5 minutes chacun
la rapporteur spéciale la commission
financière est là Véronique louvagi pour
deux minutes et les autres questions
pour une minute chacune je vous remercie
d'ailleurs par avance de bien vouloir
respecter le temps qui vous est imparti
voilà et je passe tout de suite la
parole à madame la ministre
madame la présidente madame a rapporté
en général madame a rapporteur spécial
monsieur le rapporteur pour avis
Mesdames et Messieurs les commissaires
aux affaires sociales madame la
Présidente permettez-moi d'abord en
préambule de vous faire part de mon
immense plaisir d'intervenir devant la
commission des affaires sociales à
laquelle j'ai été très fier d'appartenir
à l'occasion de cette audition pour
avoir été des vôtres durant cinq ans je
mesure l'exigence du mandat de
parlementaire et osé je le dire
particulièrement dans cette commission
qui m'est cher
la commission des affaires sociales
madame la Présidente chère Fadila c'est
celle qui s'attache à protéger les
personnes de la naissance au dernier
instant dans leur quotidien et dans
toute leur complexité les débats sont
souvent vifs parce qu'ils traitent de
l'humain jusque dans son intimité mais
toujours de haute tenue de mon côté je
m'efforcerai dans la fonction que j'ai
l'honneur d'occuper d'apporter à la
réponse à la représentation nationale
tous les éléments d'information en lien
avec mon action gouvernementale au sein
du ministère de la santé et de la
prévention j'y veillerai
j'en viens au crédit de la mission santé
la mission santé se compose à compter de
2023 de trois programmes placés sous
l'auto dorité du ministre de la Santé et
de la présence prévention François Brown
il s'agit d'une part d'un programme
placé sous la responsabilité du
directeur général de la Santé le
programme 204 relatif à la prévention à
la sécurité sanitaire et à l'offre de
soins il s'agit d'autre part de deux
programmes placés sous la responsabilité
du Directeur de la Sécurité sociale le
programme 183 protection maladie le
programme 379 qui vise à la compensation
à la sécurité sociale du coût des dons
de vaccins à des pays tiers et
reversement des recettes de la facilité
pour la relance et de la résilience FFR
européenne au titre du volley Ségur
investissement du plan national de
relance et de résilience PNR des
acronymes que vous adorez tous créez en
le programme 204 prévention sécurité
sanitaire et offre de soins vise à
améliorer l'état de santé général de la
population dans un souci de réduction
des inégalités sociales et territoriales
de santé avant la mise en place de plan
et de programmes de santé piloté au
niveau national la sécurité sanitaire
est également un champ important du
programme afin de garantir la protection
de la population face à des événements
sanitaires graves menant c'est menaçant
la santé de la population comme en
témoigne la pandémie de covid 19
trois objectifs figurent dans ce
programme prévenir le développement de
pathologies le plus en amont possible
comme par exemple avec la campagne de
vaccination contre la grippe qui
commence ce jour et que j'ai faite à mon
bras gauche en début de soirée assuré à
toute la population un dégâts accès aux
soins sur l'ensemble du territoire comme
par exemple avec le soutien de l'agence
régionale de santé à Wallis et Futuna
préparez coordonnées et piloter les
opérations de gestion de crise sanitaire
en lien avec l'ensemble des institutions
et opérateurs impliqués et en
anticipation stratégiques des riz des
risques comme par exemple le financement
du système d'information qui concourt à
la mise en oeuvre le suivi et le
pilotage de la campagne vaccinale contre
la covid 19 vaccination que j'ai
également faite aujourd'hui à mon bras
droit
l'ensemble des crédits participant à la
politique de prévention en santé menée
par l'État l'assurance maladie et les
collectivités territoriales fait
d'ailleurs l'objet depuis la loi de
finances 2021 d'une annexe dite le jaune
budgétaire dédié les exercices 2020 2021
et 2022 ont été fortement marqués par la
gestion de la crise de la covid-19 mais
2023 devrait constituer une année de
transition même si des grands événements
sportifs attendus des fins 2023 justifie
d'ores et déjà de réflexion pour
anticiper les mesures de prévention à
mettre en oeuvre en 2023 la réflexion se
poursuivra en lien avec chacun des
opérateurs dans le respect des missions
qui leur sont confiées afin d'améliorer
leur pilotage et de favoriser leur
pleine contribution aux efforts requis
dans le cadre de la programmation
pluriannuelle 2023 2027 des finances
publiques
le programme 183 protection maladie
assure en complément des politiques de
sécurité sociale la protection face à la
maladie dans des situations relevant de
la solidarité nationale ils vise
essentiellement à financer l'aide
médicale d'État dite à me dont la
gestion est assurée par la Caisse
nationale de l'assurance maladie avec un
double jeu objectif humanitaire et
sanitaire en direction des publics les
plus défavorisés
instauré en 2000 la me de droit commun
assure ainsi la protection de la santé
des personnes étrangères démunies vivant
en France en situation irrégulière
vis-à-vis du droit du au séjour et nous
pouvons donc être prise en charge par la
protection universelle maladie elle
protège les personnes concernées en leur
permettant l'accès aux soins préventifs
et curatifs et joue l'enroule important
en matière de santé publique en évitant
que les affections contagieuses non
soignées ne se propage
enfin elle permet de faciliter la prise
en charge des soins en amont évitant
ainsi les surcouliers à des soins
retarder et pratiqués dans l'urgence
depuis 2020 le gouvernement a mis en
place des mesures pour d'une part
accentuer les efforts sur la gestion des
dispositifs et la régulation de leurs
dépenses et d'autre part renforcer les
contrôles dans le cadre de programmes
d'actions ambitieux en premier lieu les
projets de centralisation de
l'instruction des demandes d'ameu et de
traitement des factures de soins urgents
ont renforcé l'efficience des dispositif
en dégageant des gains financiers grâce
à une gestion plus efficace en second
lieu afin de veiller à la juste
attribution de l'ame et garantir l'accès
aux seuls ayant droit la lutte contre
les abus et les détournements du
dispositif a été renforcé pour cela
plusieurs actions ont été engagées
obligations de déposer une primo demande
d'ame en personne à la CPAM détection
des dissimulations de visa grâce à
l'outil vis-à-bio qui permet de vérifier
si les demandeurs ne disposent pas de
visa auxquels il il serait en situation
régulière et donc non éligible à la me
application d'un délai d'ancienneté à la
me de neuf mois pour la délivrance de
certaines prestations programmées
demandent d'un accord préalable au
service du contrôle médical de la CPAM
pour les cas les plus urgents l'année
2023 sera consacrée au suivi de ces
mesures de renforcement des contrôles le
programme 183 finance également le
fondateur des victimes de l'amiante dit
FIVA créée en 2001 cet établissement
public administratif assure la
réparation des préjudices subis par les
victimes de l'amiante dont la nocivité a
été mise en évidence par les études
scientifiques et notamment le rapport de
l'Inserm de 1996 et dont l'utilisation a
été interdite en 1997 le FIVA est ainsi
l'organisme d'indemnisation
complémentaire pour les victimes
reconnues atteints d'une maladie
professionnelle
c'est aussi l'unique organisme
d'indemnisation pour les personnes ne
bénéficiant pas d'une couverture contre
les risques accidents du travail et
maladies professionnelles notamment
celle atteinte de pathologies causées
par l'amiante du fait de leur exposition
au titre autre que professionnel
familial domestique ou environnemental
enfin le programme 379 créé en PLF 2023
va permettre à l'État de reverser à la
sécurité sociale les crédits européens
perçus dans le cadre du plan national de
relance et de résilience au titre du
volley investissement du Ségur de la
santé ce qui correspond à une somme de
1,13 milliards d'euros pour 2023 versés
aux établissements de santé et aux
établissements médico-sociaux
il ne porte donc pas en tant que tel de
politique publique ce programme a pour
finalité de reverser des crédits
européens à la sécurité sociale par
l'intermédiaire de crédit budgétaire les
trois programmes que je viens d'évoquer
participent pleinement en complément des
crédits mobilisés dans le cadre du
budget de la Sécurité Sociale et les
fesses à la mise en œuvre de la
politique globale de santé dont les
objectifs sont de développer la
prévention d'assurer la sécurité
sanitaire et d'organiser une offre de
soins de qualité accessible à l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens je vous remercie
merci bien madame la ministre nous
allons donc passer au à notre orateur
déjà donc je lui donne la parole pour 10
minutes la rapporteur pardon le
rapporteur pardon le rapporteur monsieur
Benz vous avez le téléphone la parole
[Rires]
voilà c'est mieux comme ça je vous en
prie
madame la ministre madame la Présidente
chère collègue la désertification
médicale et les difficultés d'accès aux
soins constituent une préoccupation
majeure des Français notre système
hospitalier est gravement malade il se
dégrade depuis les décennies dans le
même temps le tissu de médecine de
proximité dans les villes et villages de
France se délitent les Français se
heurtent à des difficultés quotidiennes
de la simple ordonnance au plus grave le
renoncement aux soins faute de service
de soins de proximité faute de pouvoir y
accéder faute de médecins sur leur
territoire de nombreux Français
subissent le recul des services de soins
avec parfois des implications très
graves comme la perte de chance d'être
soignée pour une maladie qui aurait dû
être traitée plus tôt
le sentiment d'abandon en la matière
correspond à un abandon réel la colère
de la population est palpable dans ma
circonscription à titre d'exemple une
manifestation historique pour sauver les
services hospitaliers de Langres à réuni
plus de 2000 personnes qui ont défilé en
juin dernier dans cette commune de 7000
habitants cet exemple témoigne de
l'urgence criante de la situation en
parallèle avant de continuer à
développer ce sujet central voici un
avis concernant les crédits de la
mission santé du PLF pour 2023 les
crédits basés sur des indicateurs
généralistes ne tiennent pas compte des
spécificités et disparités sociales
territoriales le programme 204 de
prévention sécurité sanitaire et offre
de soins est en augmentation surtout
expliquer par l'augmentation des crédits
pour la prévention des risques liés à
l'environnement et l'alimentation et la
préparation des crises sanitaires
si ces deux objectifs sont importants
trop peu d'éléments se trouvent dans les
documents budgétaires pour véritablement
comprendre à quelle mesure concrètes
seront dédiées ces crédits ensuite le
programme 183 qui recouvre
principalement les dépenses liées à
l'aide médicale d'État est en
augmentation de plus de 12% la hausse de
la me est supérieure à la hausse de
l'ensemble de la mission santé le nombre
de bénéficiaires de l'AME était de plus
de 380 000 ans 2021 contre 208 000 974
en 2011 soit une augmentation de 82 % en
10 ans dans ces conditions il paraît
nécessaire de remettre en cause la prise
en charge certains soins composant le
panier de soins de l'Ame dentaire
obstétrique gynécologie optique etc
indispensable de réformer la mme dont la
vocation a été largement dévoyée et
revenir à la philosophie d'origine de
cette aide qui avait pour but d'apporter
uniquement des soins à caractère urgent
et de lutter contre les maladies
contingieuses importées de l'étranger
dans un souci de protection des Français
et de la santé publique nationale en
2021 d'ailleurs la Cour des comptes
avait déjà alerté sur l'augmentation
exponentielle de l'aide médicale d'État
au-delà des montants la dimension de
contrôle largement suffisante seule 14%
des dossiers me sont aujourd'hui
contrôlés et aucune augmentation des
prévue programme 374 les comptes publics
doivent faire l'objet d'une bonne
lisibilité comme la Cour des comptes le
demande or l'ajout de ce programme
traitant du remboursement par
l'assurance maladie du coût des dons de
vaccins des pays étrangers ne facilitent
pas la bonne lecture de l'évolution des
crédits de la mission santé il fait plus
que doubler artificiellement la masse
des crédits affectés à la mission santé
sur cette mission donc avis défavorable
car les crédits ne correspondent pas
pour la majorité de ce budget consacré
aux demandes et aux besoins de nos
compatriotes les Français nous hurlent
leur désarroi quant à l'accès aux soins
dans de nombreux territoires le
gouvernement doit les écouter lors des
auditions que nous avons effectuées de
nombreux constats ont été partagés de
nombreuses pistes de solutions ont
rencontré une forme de consensus le
temps du constat est maintenant révolu
il s'agit de passer à l'action le
constat chiffré d'abord il est sans
appel en France 87 médecins pour 100000
habitants mais avec de très fortes
disparités territoriales 50% des
médecins ont actuellement plus de 60 ans
6 millions de Français non pas de
médecins traitant et 10% d'entre eux
pourtant souffrent d'une infection de
longue durée
des milliers de Français renoncent
chaque année il y a une rupture
d'égalité entre les différents
territoires dans l'accès aux soins
rupture grandement due à la
métropolisation des services de santé ce
qui mène souvent à des différences
d'espérance de vie les problématiques
d'accessibilité aux soins doivent être
évalués au niveau départemental ou en
fonction des bassins de vie et non au
niveau national ni même régional le
risque de renoncement soin est accru
pour les personnes modestes et qui se
trouvent dans une zone de faible densité
médicale il y a une réelle perte de
chance pour les patients et davantage de
mortalité dans les zones soudenses le
recours à la télémédecine
est une solution très partiel et
insuffisamment efficace c'est un outil
parfois utile notamment pour la
télésurveillance post intervention ou
les consultations avaient des
spécialistes simultanément mais le lien
social et humain avec un professionnel
de santé reste primordial plus
globalement c'est la révélation des
professions médicales qui permettra de
renouer avec l'attractivité des métiers
de la santé parmi les solutions à
développer il nous faut agir sur les
déterminants de l'installation des
médecins premier déterminant le lien
avec la zone d'installation or le profil
des étudiants en médecine est très
urbain et davantage issus de classe
moyenne supérieure deuxième déterminant
la présence de services publics et
d'infrastructures médicales qui
participent à l'attractivité d'un
territoire enfin on constate un décalage
entre le nombre suffisant d'étudiants
qui souhaitent effectuer leur stage en
zone soudoté et le nombre 1 suffisant de
mettre de stage volontaires dans les
territoires
il faut agir contre l'éloignement des
formations par rapport au territoire
grâce notamment à l'introduction accrue
de stage les étudiants je les dis ils
sont prêts l'ajout d'une quatrième année
d'internat proposé par le gouvernement
pour la médecine la date intérêts que si
elle profite prioritairement aux zones
dans le besoin les stages de formation
pratique peuvent être développées bien
en amont dans le cursus dès les
premières années d'études
inciter les médecins à devenir maître de
stage pour les inciter il faut valoriser
cette mission essentielle de
transmission du savoir
et de pratique empiriques l'augmentation
des moyens aux étudiants pour se
déplacer indemnité de transport et
d'hébergement pour les stages éloignés
du lieu de formation l'ouverture de
centre de formation dans les zones moins
bien dotées
pour les médecins en exercice poursuivre
la libération du temps médical
délégation de tâches des médecins
notamment aux infirmiers en pratique
avancées et assistant médicaux pour
suivre les mesures d'exonération et de
cumules en pleurs retraite afin que les
médecins retraités n'aient plus à
acquitter les cotisations de retraite
qui ne leur ouvre aucun droit ou encore
fixer les conditions de préavis après le
départ d'un médecin en zone soudance
enfin sur le mode de régulation des
médecins sommes-nous encore dans un
temps où l'incitation suffit ou
devons-nous au vu du degré d'urgence
introduit à des dispositifs plus
contraignants pour une période
provisoire une période de moyen terme
notamment pour la période sensible de
2022 à 2030
si l'ouverture du numéro exclusus a été
positivement accueilli il doit être
nécessairement assorti d'un mode de
régulation territoriale pour une
répartition maîtrisée afin d'inciter à
l'installation dans les zones qui ont le
plus besoin ce débat doit être posé sans
tabou c'est pourquoi cet avis budgétaire
liste les nombreuses idées et pistes de
solutions à court moyen et long terme
qui ont été évoqués lors des auditions
en conclusion de nombreux Français n'ont
plus accès aux soins minimum dans les
déserts médicaux qui touchent beaucoup
de territoires alors même que les
Français sont censés être les premiers
bénéficiaires de la solidarité nationale
qui par définition doit être nationale
dans le même temps financer des soins du
quotidien au titre de l'Ame au bénéfice
d'étrangers clandestins qui donc violent
notre droit pour plus d'un milliard
d'euros et en augmentation constitue un
choix politique très contestable la
générosité de la France ne peut se faire
au détriment de nombreux nationaux qui
ont tous droits à un accès aux soins de
qualité digne et de proximité lorsque la
France n'exerce plus totalement cette
mission de santé publique et de
protection de la vie des français par
renoncement par choix ou par
incompétence alors l'état failli
gravement il met en danger en danger de
nombreux Français être français est une
chance est un privilège c'est aussi un
certain nombre de droits auxquels ils
doivent pouvoir prétendre les Français
cotisent et paix des impôts pour avoir
accès aux soins et au passage
qui nous Élise pour les défendre
répondre à la problématique de la
désertification médicale avec rapidité
et efficacité est un impératif le
gouvernement n'a plus le droit à
l'erreur il faut corriger cette fracture
médicale qui frappe durement les zones
périphériques en menant des politiques
de rééquilibrage avec une logique de
bassin de vie et non de métropolisation
des services publics c'est une question
de justice territoriale concernant le
mode de régulation et d'installation des
médecins qui ont une mission de service
public sans nouvelles actions
d'incitation maximale nous dirigerons
inéluctablement vers un système de
coercition qui n'est pas souhaitable au
nom de la protection de la santé de tous
les Français dans un pays qui
malheureusement est en voie de tiers
mondialisation médicale ou des milliers
de Français renoncent chaque année à se
soigner imagine-t-on un quoi qu'il en
coûte contre la désertification médicale
des contraintes temporaires pour
installer des médecins en zone sous
dotée
l'État doit ensuite faire confiance au
territoire aux communes et départements
en premier lieu et aux acteurs locaux de
la santé pour assurer la bonne
coordination des services au plus près
des réalités l'enjeu est donc de sauver
notre système de santé et notre tissu
territorial d'offre de soins cette
impératif cette urgence les Français
nous le demandent je vous remercie
merci
donc aux orateurs de groupe et c'est
Madame Laurence Cristol pour le groupe
Renaissance je sais pas si le micro
marche c'était comme tout à l'heure
allez-y
merci madame la Présidente
ça marche
madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur les crédits de la mission
santé s'élève cette année à 3,36
milliards d'euros en augmentation de
plus de
159,44% par rapport au crédit ouvert
l'an dernier cette augmentation est
celle des programmes 183 et 204 mais
s'explique principalement par la
création du programme 379 qui n'appelle
pas de remarques particulières
sur le programme 183 concernant l'ame et
le FIVA on remarquera une hausse d'un
budget essentiel pour des raisons
humanitaires sanitaires et économiques
l'ame répond à la solvabilité d'une
demande de soins qui doit être honorée
en respect des conventions humanitaires
européennes et internationales qui
constitue le droit universel à la vie et
à la santé cette augmentation étant
large partie du comme le note le
rapporteur un effet de rattrapage des
soins suite à la crise sanitaire mais
aussi à une hausse des tarif
hospitaliers et une augmentation du
point d'indice sur ce sujet on a tout à
fait le droit d'être dans l'opposition
par principe on peut aussi regarder de
manière pragmatique les conditions
d'accès à l'AME mieux encadrés par la
réforme de 2019 les conditions de
ressources la vérification des
conditions de séjour les conditions
d'octroi et de renouvellement le
périmètre réel de la prise en charge des
soins on peut aussi voir les dossiers
contrôlés donc on peut débattre et il
faut débattre on le fait chaque année il
faudra pouvoir tirer sur cette réforme
sur la prévention et le programme 204
inépuise pas à lui seul le financement
important de l'État pour la prévention
puisqu'il se retrouve dans 24 programmes
recensés par le jeune budgétaire
prévention ensemble c'est bien là la
transcription de la formule la santé
dans toutes les politiques ce programme
complète également avec une augmentation
non négligeable des crédits de certaines
actions les dépenses de l'assurance
maladie remarquons d'ailleurs que
certains amendements que nous
discuterons tout à l'heure relève bien
du PLFSS et non du PLF mais la Cour des
comptes le rappelait dans un rapport
publié à un an le programme le problème
n'est pas tant le niveau de financement
de la prévention que la multiplication
des circuits de financement et dont des
circuits de décision cette situation qui
nuit à l'organisation de la politique et
donc à son efficacité on peut
s'interroger madame la ministre peut-on
espérer à moyen terme une
restructuration de la manière dont est
financée la prévention et espérer une
pluri annualité des financements
ma deuxième question sur ce programme
porte sur la subvention pour charge
service public à l'Institut National du
Cancer ces crédits et son plafond
d'emploi sont les mêmes que ce voter
pour 2022 dans un contexte où la
nouvelle stratégie décennale appelle au
lancement d'un nombre important de
mesure au nombre de 42 en 2023 ses
crédits et ce plafond d'emploi
seront-ils suffisants pour que l'Inca
assure ses missions enfin nous sommes
quelques-uns à être interpellés sur la
situation de l'Établissement français du
sang qui fait notamment face à des
pénuries de professionnels pouvant
affecter les réserves de sang déjà sous
forte tension pouvez-vous me préciser
comment le gouvernement entend soutenir
les FS
ces remarques et ces questions posées
ces crédits étant essentiels à notre
politique de prévention et de protection
des plus fragiles je ne doute pas que
nous nous retrouverons sur le vote de
cette mission le groupe Renaissance
votera ses crédit
merci bien la parole est à Sandrine
d'ogort Suk pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre depuis la
mi-septembre le Conseil économique
social et environnemental c'est attelé à
l'organisation d'une convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie je souhaite
revenir sur l'extrême complexité de
cette question les lois de 2005 et de
2016 concernant le droit des malades et
la fin de vie des fins de trois
principes donnant abandons de non
souffrances de noncharnement elles
permettent d'accompagner des personnes
en fin de vie mais n'autorise pas à
donner la mort la vie humaine et la
valeur suprême de notre civilisation on
ne peut cependant pas nier la demande de
sociétale de l'égalisation de
l'euthanasie même si sa mise en pratique
est loin d'être simple nous devons faire
face à un manque de moyens mis dans les
services de soins palliatifs et qui
entraînent une véritable inégalité
d'accès à un Caden accompagnement de en
fin de vie
l'amélioration de la qualité de la prise
en charge en fin de vie doit être une
priorité les soins palliatifs doivent
pouvoir offrir à chacun des conditions
de vie digne au soir de l'existence
permettez-moi de rappeler que 26
départements en France ne disposent
toujours pas de services de soins
palliatifs 300 000 personnes en ont
besoin et seuls
les lois qui existent apportent des
solutions aux angoisses de nos
concitoyens elle permettent de
démystifier la fin de vie de faire
confiance aux soignants afin de vivre
les choses différemment mais elle peine
à devenir effective car les moyens de
développement des soins palliatifs ne
sont pas mis en place la crainte de
souffrir a été mise au premier plan pour
justifier l'aide à mourir aujourd'hui
cette demande de sociétale s'est
transformée en une revendications
idéologique le respect de libre arbitre
le droit de disposer de soi-même jusque
dans les conditions de l'amour si le
respect de la dignité est souvent avancé
pour justifier me demande de l'aide à
mourir peut-on réellement apprécier la
dignité à l'homme de l'autonomie
apparente d'une personne doit-on estimer
qu'une personne très dépendante devienne
indigne de vivre n'est-ce pas un danger
que la société organise la mort d'une
personne comme réponse un manque
d'autonomie notre tournant nous pas
alors dans une société qui ne
protégerait plus les plus vulnérables la
dame mourir doit être entrée dans le
champ de soins
demandez au corps soignant de provoquer
la mort n'est-ce pas le contraire de
pourquoi il fait son métier et quelle
place alors donner à l'accompagnement
des malades la crainte sera alors de les
enfermer dans une solution unique et la
relation de confiance qui existe entre
le patient et le soignant sera faussé
l'interdit de tuer permet aux malades
d'exprimer ses allers-retours entre
désirs de mort et désir de vie quand le
malade arrive en soins palliatif en
exprimant son souhait de mourir l'équipe
accueille sa demande en s'interrogeant
sur la demande de sous-jacente il est
témoignage révèle que la plupart des
malades n'ont en réalité pas envie de
mourir
nous voudriez donc pas Madame la
Ministre travailler sur une approche
innovante qui permettrait de concilier
la demande de nos concitoyens d'être
plus autonome et plus libre au moment de
leur fin de vie avec l'engagement
soignant des professionnels qui pensent
qu'il y aurait un risque à considérer
que provoquer intentionnellement le
décès d'une personne puisse relever d'un
geste médical merci
merci bien monsieur Damien Maudet pour
la France insoumise du Pesse je vous
donne le micro pensez à éteindre vos
micro après votre intervention mes chers
collègues merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre
le 12 mars 2020 Emmanuel Macron nous
disait ce que révèle cette pandémie
c'est que la santé gratuite sans
condition de revenus de parcours ou de
profession notre État providence ne sont
pas des coûts des charges mais des biens
précieux les atouts indispensables quand
le destin frappe je crois qu'en 2020 et
on peut tous être d'accord Emmanuel
Macron avait les bons mots et il était
en phase en vérité avec ce que demandait
la population et d'ailleurs si pour
beaucoup de soignants le covid a été un
moment de souffrance il a aussi été un
moment d'immense espoir l'espoir d'un
État qui se préoccupe en fin de la santé
fini le président qui vient expliquer
aux soignants qu'il n'y a pas de
problème de financement mais que ce ne
sont que des problèmes d'organisation
fini le président qui lorsqu'il dit au
médecin qu'il compte sur eux ces
derniers peuvent lui répondre pouvaient
compter sur nous mais l'inverse reste à
prouver
mais bon comme le disait Clémenceau on
ne ment jamais autant que durant les
guerres ou les élections ça tombe bien
on était en guerre et pas très loin des
élections et donc que s'est-il passé
depuis ces beaux mots les soignants ont
tenus ou tendent de tenir et le
gouvernement a trahi oui il a trahi et
collectivement le gouvernement tous les
membres ont trahi que s'est-il passé
depuis 2020 les plans hospitaliers n'ont
pas cessé les restrictions budgétaires
existent encore les soignants sont
dégoûtés et finissent par partir vers le
libéral l'intérim voire des fois change
complètement de métier d'ailleurs on
avait même eu une fois Olivier Véran qui
nous expliquait qu'il allait contacter
Pôle emploi pour essayer de convaincre
les soignants de revenir c'est dans le
JDD à tel point qu'en octobre avant le
rebond un autre rebond épidémique le
Conseil Scientifique faisait l’état que
20% des liés étaient fermés faute de
soignants d'ailleurs même sur les
réanimations qui était la variable
d'ajustement du confinement plus elles
étaient saturées plus on était confinées
la Cour des comptes expliquée entre
juillet et octobre 2020 nous n'avons pas
relevé de décision annonciatrice de
modifications structurelles pour les
soins critiques aucune décision n'a été
prise qui pourrait expliquer que les
pouvoirs publics envisagaient une
évolution sur les autres services c'est
guère mieux les leadospitations
complètes fermes les résultats en
chiffres on a eu les données de
l'adresse qui ont été rectifiées ensuite
de 4900 lits supprimés en 2020 et 4300
lits supprimés en 2021 ça ce sont les
chiffres de l'adresse donc votre
ministère
et aujourd'hui
dans nos projets de budgétaires que
préparez-vous des économies et des
concertations des économies comme si
nous n'avions pas eu de covid pas eu de
fermeture des urgences cet été comme si
tout s'est bien passé alors que la
Commission des contes de la Sécu nous
explique qu'il faut augmenter l'ONDAM
donc le budget de 4% par an pour suivre
l'évolution en fonction des besoins on
nous propose dans la programmation
budgétaire pour 2024 2025 de passer sous
les 3%. donc la traduction vous
sous-investissez dans l'hôpital la
deuxième traduction vous économisez sur
l'hôpital et sur la santé et bon on a de
la chance puisque en parallèle de tout
ça vous concertez c'est à dire que on a
le CNR santé donc après avoir acté le
budget après avoir déjà préparé votre
budget de sécurité sociale après avoir
avoué que vous allez utiliser le 49-3 on
en parlait encore tout à l'heure et bien
vous menez des concertations maintenant
vous concerter après avoir décidé de
tout
tout est déjà aggravé dans le marbre et
vous allez faire croire aux gens qui
peuvent qu'on peut encore discuter
alors pour éviter c'est ces nouvelles
discussions que de toute façon on a vu
vous n'avez pas tellement envie d'avoir
avec mon groupe politique on a organisé
cet été des recueils de doléances on
allait dans les CHU de toute la France
80 établissements de santé on a récupéré
500 témoignages l'opération s'appelait
allocs
et quelles ont été les résultats je vous
les donne peut-être que ça peut nous
faire gagner du temps deux tiers des
soignants sont soumis à des risques
psychosociaux les soignants font leur
métier mais souvent ils nous disent
qu'ils ont l'impression de maltraiter
les gens il y a une perte de sens il n'a
même certains qui nous disent qu'ils
passent leur temps à s'excuser parce
qu'ils n'ont pas le temps de s'occuper
des gens à Limoges encore il y a pas si
longtemps une personne a passé 96 heures
sur un brancard on nous raconte qu'il y
a des chimios qui sont des programmes au
dernier moment vous imaginant bien tout
le stress que ça peut avoir que d'avoir
à faire ce type ce type d'intervention
qui sont annulés au dernier moment et
donc face à tout ça je pourrais encore
vous faire le constat mais je pense
qu'on vous enverra le rapport
moi plutôt que des concertations
j'aimerais surtout qu'on nous ramène le
François Brune de 2019 que je vais vous
citer un plan Macron pour les urgences
s'imposent pour que les urgentistes ne
soient plus les funambules d'un système
de soins abandonnés pour que l'hôpital
public retrouve sa place en tant que
pilier de la République l'avant-garde de
l'hôpital est souvent du système de
soins vous alerte sur cette nécessité
historique l'hôpital public brûle à
petit feu les soignants sont sacrifiés
sur l'hôtel d'une finance aveuglée par
l'activité et une tarification des
uettes si jamais vous retrouvez le
François brun de 2019 on en aurait bien
besoin
merci la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
Juvin pour les républicains merci madame
la présidente madame la ministre
le premier premier chapitre c'est sur le
chapitre de prévention
et là comment dire je pense que dans
d'autres pays il faut qu'on comprenne
que la santé c'est l'hôpital sont les
systèmes de soins mais c'est aussi la
qualité de l'air qu'on respire de
l'alimentation qu'on mange de l'eau
qu'on boit c'est la question des talades
dans l'environnement c'est toute ce
principe que il vaut mieux prévenir un
cancer que d'essayer de le guérir alors
je sais que tout le monde le dit tout le
monde parle de santé unique mais quand
on voit les chiffres du programme de
prévention on est très troublé le
problème de prévention augmente de 1,56%
en réalité ça signifie qui baisse compte
tenu de l'inflation avec des niveaux de
moyens qui sont mis à disposition qui
sont trop faibles moi je crois qu'il
faut que nous fassions vraiment un
effort sur la prévention sinon notre
système curatif n'y arrivera pas
la santé c'est une santé unique deuxième
point il y a le chapitre sur l'aide
médicale d'État alors l'aide médicale
d'État ce qui est préoccupant c'est son
caractère massif et massivement
inexorable qui augmente chaque année
plus 155% en 15 ans
et
parallèlement cette impression qu'au
fond c'est vrai il y a quelques mesures
qui ont été prises vous avez raison de
les rappeler madame la ministre et ce
sont des mesures qui ne sont pas
structurelles donc nous allons faire des
propositions parce que cette
augmentation de l'Ame mange la
quasi-totalité du budget si on met de
côté le chapitre sur les vaccins qui est
en fait une opération d'ordre entre
budget de l'État et less
l'ame c'est 83% du budget que nous
discutions de ce soir
83%. donc la me il faut évidemment un
chapitre sur la question des fraudes
vous l'avez dit un chapitre parce que là
aussi on n'y arrivera pas si on aide pas
massivement les pays d'origine des gens
en situation irrégulière si on n'est pas
leurs hôpitaux si on ne les aide pas
massivement dans le pays d'origine et
bien on aura une immigration qui sera
une immigration qui serait qui
continuera à être une migration de
recherche de soi fort légitimement parce
que les gens veulent se faire soigner il
faut aider les populations y compris
dans leur pays d'origine et puis je
pense aussi qu'il faut faire de la
prévention de je suis très frappé du
fait qu'il n'y ait pas de consultation
de prévention à l'entrée dans le système
et ça ça fera l'objet de d'amendement
que nous allons proposer et puis il y a
également tout ce qu'il n'y a pas et
tout ce qu'il n'y a pas et bien tout ce
qui manque dans chapitre j'ai ciblé
quelques quelques points d'abord la
question du covidon le covidon c'est
probablement l'épidémie qui nous menace
et qui en réalité déjà présente même si
on ne la voit pas alors on la voit pas
parce qu'en France on a cette
caractéristique c'est qu'on ne mesure
pas les choses les Anglais ont mesuré
que 1,8 millions de dollars concitoyens
avaient un covidon à trois mois 800
000 c'est ce que disent les Britanniques
ont un covidon à un an il faut donc
imaginer qu'à 800 000 britanniques qui
ont des séquelles qui les empêchent de
reprendre une activité normale c'est pas
un problème de santé enfin pas seulement
c'est un problème social c'est quasiment
un problème économique et donc cette
question du covidon
la recherche fondamentale
l'épidémiologie les consultations moi je
sais pas en tant que médecin ou envoyer
un covidon aujourd'hui et quelque chose
qui est très préoccupant et ça y est pas
il faut vraiment s'en occuper il y a un
deuxième point qu'il n'y ait pas c'est
la question de la rémunération des
professionnels de santé sur une partie
particulière de leur activité qui est
celle de la nuit et du week-end c'est ce
qu'on appelle la permanence des soins
François Brown a pris une très bonne
mesure ce cet été en augmentant doublant
la rémunération des
professions de santé sur la permanence
des soins et il faut continuer il faut
surtout pas arrêter parce que la
question du week-end la question de la
nuit c'est une question clé dans
l'acceptabilité de la dureté du métier
et ça ça y est pas il y a rien sur les
soins palliatifs on va parler de
l'euthanasie on parle pas des soins
palliatifs pardon mais là il y a un tout
petit sujet tout ça est lié
il y a rien sur les déserts médicaux
mais d'autres en ont parlé il y a rien
sur la santé mentale TA santé mentale de
la population n'est pas bonne
on a fait pour l'incaille à soupçonner
pour le cancer il y a quelques années
l'incarme qui a bouleversé la prise en
charge des cancers moi je pense qu'il
faut qu'on fasse l'inquin maintenant
pour la santé mentale il faut que on
sorte de la paupérisation ce système de
soins psychiatriques et psychiques en
France qui est vraiment très pauvre
enfin il y a rien sur la mortalité
infantile qui ne fait qu'augmenter
depuis une dizaine d'années notre pays
d'une manière très préoccupante au moins
qu'on analyse pourquoi elle augmente
parce qu'aujourd'hui ces choses se sont
pas claires donc voilà madame la
ministre je trouve qu'il y a une
paupérisation du système je trouve qu'il
y a beaucoup de choses qui manquent je
trouve que la mu consomme 83% du budget
et donc il faut la réformer et puis vous
pouvez compter sur les républicains pour
faire des propositions d'amendement
nombreuses pour tenter d'améliorer ce
budget merci
merci monsieur le député je dis juste
une chose je dis rien
l'audition elle porte sur les crédits de
la mission santé enfin je dis ça je dis
rien
voilà moi aussi depuis tout à l'heure je
me dis on n'est pas dans le bel effet 16
ou voilà dans ok donc je passe la parole
à Monsieur Cyril Isaac Sibille non mais
je dis ça donc la ministre va pas
pouvoir vous répondre à toutes les
questions monsieur Sybille Isa Sibyl
vous avez la parole et lui seul à la
parole
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre cher Agnès je vous remercie
pour la présentation exhaustive des
objectifs de la mise en santé du projet
de lot-finance 2023 je souhaiterais
évoquer avec vous les enjeux de la
politique de prévention et mon propos se
consacrera sur le programme demi 204 qui
rassemble les actions de l'État pour la
prévention santé
vous ne les rappelez ce programme
vis-à-vis du résultat de santé général
de la population dans un souci de
réduction des inégalités sociales et
territoriales de santé qui nous le
savons sont grandes or quelques points
mérite d'être précisé les indicateurs
dans la mission santé deux indicateurs
très subjectifs et déclaratifs sont
utilisés l'état de santé aperçu par les
répondants
et l'espérance de vie sans incapacité
concernant le programme de 104 les
indicateurs sont le taux de couverture
vaccinale contre la grippe le taux de
participation dépistage du colocat
colorectal l'eau potable présentant des
déplacements de qualité microbiologique
et la prévalence du tabagisme
pour le programme 24 que nous examinons
concernant l'action 11 qui se contraint
qui se consacrent au pilotage
de la santé publique les deux tiers des
crédits sont consacrés aux actions
contentes
concernant l'action 14 qui se consacre
aux maladies chroniques 80% sont
consacrés à l'Inca et 10% à la lutte
contre le tabac et l'alcool 2% à la
prévention de la santé mentale qui
représente 7 millions de patients
écoutent de milliards de milliards par
an avec vous et d'autres collègues nous
avons obtenu il y a quelques temps un
jaune budgétaire concernant les actions
de l'état de l'assurance maladie et des
collectivités concernant la prévention
santé et je conseille mes collègues de
le lire
à ce jour il recense les dépenses
suivantes 3 milliards dans le budget de
l'État pour l'appréhension un milliard 4
pour les collectivités et 1 milliard 3
dépensé par l'assurance maladie que
savons vous et qu'affirmer qu'a
confirmer la récente crise de santé
publique que nous devons agir avec une
approche populationnelle et non
seulement individuelle j'ai de devoir
agir sur les déterminants de santé que
de nevons que nous devons aller vers les
populations les plus éloignées du
système de santé je les déterminant en
santé éducatifs sociaux environnementaux
sont responsables de 80% de notre santé
alors que le système de soins de
participe ne participe qu'à 20% à notre
santé face à la fragmentation de la
politique en faveur de la prévention
santé
comment faire pour mieux définir des
objectifs d'une politique de prévention
lui donner un pilote est-ce que c'est
l'état ce que c'est l'assurance maladie
et un cadrage national choisir les bons
indicateurs pour la piloter
unifier les outils de communication on
entend souvent des messages message du
ministère à la radio missage ministère
d'Assurance Maladie
de du ministère de l'assurance maladie
et des scientifiques France et comment
faire pour rassembler un petit peu tous
ces financements ils sont divers et
variés
concernant la médicale d'État nous la
considérons comme essentiel elle ne sera
jamais remise en cause sur les bandes et
démocrates se posent la question de la
carence de trois mois
pour ces migrants qui pour nous devra
bénéficier dès leur arrivée d'une
constellation dépistage je salue par le
par ailleurs l'arrivée du nouveau
programme 379 379 destinés à mettre en
place la partie investissement du Ségur
pouvez-vous nous préciser le flechage
des 2 milliards d'euros de crédit de
cette mission et notamment le volet de
transformation numérique des
établissements
le groupe démocrate votre a bien
évidemment les crédits de cette mission
ils regrette cependant l'insuffisance
des crédits affectée au programme
prévention
qui devrait qui pourrait permettre
l'émergence d'une politique nationale
d'ampleur comme le laisse présager la
dynamisation du ministère chargé de la
santé et de la prévention je vous
remercie
merci bien monsieur Guedj n'étant pas là
je passe à la parole à Monsieur Frédéric
valtoux pour horizon et apparenté
oui madame madame la présidente monsieur
le rapporteur mais mes chers collègues
je pense qu'en matière de santé il faut
être assez humble c'est à dire que c'est
un sujet compliqué sur lequel tant de
gouvernement tant de majorité ce sont
casser les dents les médecins qui vont
arriver sur le dans l'exercice sur les
médecins qui ont démarré leurs études
entre 2007 et 2013 on va voir s'ils sont
plus nombreux cette année dans les
années qui suivent qui ne l'était
jusqu'à présent et on verra concrètement
peut-être effectivement avec humilité
que finalement
les les certitudes d'aujourd'hui renvoie
quand même à des à des erreurs d'hier ce
que je veux dire en la matière c'est que
j'avais pas compris qu'on discutait là
de l'ensemble de la politique de santé
si c'est le cas moi je voudrais saluer
madame la ministre les premières
semaines ou les premiers mois de
démarrage au ministère il y a eu un très
beau communiqué de tous les ordres il y
a quelques jours
c'était une première alors on peut
trouver que il y a pas de il y a pas de
il y a pas de réponse encore immédiate
mais en tout cas il y a un engagement de
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé à
travailler ensemble à réfléchir ensemble
et pour mettre heurté au syndicat de
médecins un certain nombre de fois je
sais à quel point c'est pas toujours les
personnes les plus faciles à faire
bouger et donc bravo déjà pour ce
résultat qui permet au moins d'ouvrir
l'espoir que les professionnels de santé
ont dû être convaincus qu'il y avait
aussi une part de responsabilité
dans leur dans leurs actions et dans
leur positionnement et que une part de
la réponse était pas toujours l'état
c'était pas toujours les gouvernements
mais c'était aussi ceux qui font le soin
sur le terrain qui pouvaient qui
pouvaient l'imaginer alors sur ce sur le
le la mission santé qui est dans le PDF
de 2023 évidemment horizon soutien les
engagements et un seul chiffre 3,4
milliards d'euros augmentation de
159%, il y a des explications
effectivement à l'augmentation de ce
budget mais globalement on voit que
l'ensemble des budgets augmentent et que
donc l'effort est continue on peut
trouver que ça va passer vite on veut
trouver que ça va passer loin mais
globalement moi je préfère dire que
effectivement les forts l'effort
s'intensifient et que progressivement on
va vers la résolution des des problèmes
la prévention est-ce qu'il faut juger la
qualité de notre système de santé en
matière de prévention à l'unique ligne
budgétaire qui est dans ce texte moi je
ne le pense pas je pense que comme très
bien rappelé Philippe juin c'est une
question d'environnement c'est une
question d'aménagement des villes c'est
une question de circulation automobile
c'est une question de plein de choses
d'alimentation et donc tous nos figure
pas dans cette ligne budgétaire donc de
jeter que la prévention ça va passer
loin parce que le la ligne budgétaire
prévention tout en disant
qu'effectivement elle ressort de tout un
tas de facteurs qui n'ont rien à voir
avec la dite Ludivine GTR je trouve ça
effectivement un petit peu un petit peu
un petit peu rapide il y a la volonté
effectivement d'aller vers un système
qui est sera peut-être demain moins
curatif plus préventif ça demande des
évolutions dans le système de
financement ça dépend des évolutions
dans les pratiques professionnelles et
soignantes ça demande des évolutions à
certains nombres de niveaux qui sont
effectivement complexes à opérer et on
peut pas dire en tous les cas que on
prenne un mauvais pli en matière de en
matière de de prévention moi je rejoins
je rejoins leurs cristal pardon à
l'instant lorsqu'elle dit
qu'effectivement il va falloir aller
vers plus de pluraluité des financements
mais c'est pas l'objet du rapport c'est
l'objet du PLFSS et j'espère que on y
arrivera il va falloir effectivement
orienter la politique de santé vers une
régulation plus ferme des dépenses pour
qu'effectivement
flêcher ses dépenses de santé qui sont
déjà qui représentent 230 240 milliards
d'euros total dans notre pays pour les
orienter vers des dépenses qui
améliorent le soin réellement plus que
effectivement qu'elle servent certaines
rentes et donc ça demande effectivement
un peu de fermeté dans le pilotage des
portes de santé mais on a eu ce débat et
on si on nous permet de l'avoir dans le
PLFSS et puis moi je voudrais quand même
répondre à notre collègue de LFI sur les
bonbons d'Emmanuel Macron je pense que
les soignants ils perçoivent les bons
enfin ce que vous appelez les les bons
mots d'Emmanuel Macron en 2020 parce que
finalement voilà un président qui pour
la première fois a mis les actes en
reflet avec ses engagements quand on met
19 milliards d'euros dans
l'investissement hospitalier alors qu'on
était tombé si bas depuis 2005 dans
l'investissement hospitalier qui était à
l'os entre 2005 et 2017 l'investissement
hospitalier était à l'os vous le voulez
ou vous le voulez pas mais regardez les
chiffres ils disent les choses très
concrètes on relance de 19 milliards
investissements ça n'a jamais été fait
quand on met 20 quand on met 10
milliards d'euros 9 milliards pardon 9
milliards d'euros sur les sur les sur
les salaires c'est concret les salaires
c'est à la sur la fiche de paye à la fin
de chaque mois 10% de hausse de salaire
montrer donnez-moi un autre secteur qui
a bénéficié de 10% de hausse de salaire
net comme ça en quelques mois ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est sans doute pas
tout le chemin n'a pas été fait il y a
encore de nombreuses étapes pour
effectivement regonfler remettre à flot
notre système de santé mais on peut pas
toujours lui taper dessus on peut pas
toujours dire que ces hospitaliers les
pauvres je veux dire n'ont pas les
moyens de travailler quand il a fallu
quand il y a eu la crise ils ont eu les
moyens de répondre effectivement au
enjeux qui étaient qui étaient ceux de
santé et donc à partir de là pour
terminer parce que c'est la fin ce
budget va dans le bon sens et je le
soutiens à pleinement merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame
Marie-Charlotte gara pour l'écologie
nupes
merci madame la Présidente je m'adresse
à vous au nom du député Sébastien Petavy
qui est toujours hospitalisé madame la
ministre madame la présidente monsieur
le rapporteur chers collègues vous
présentez une augmentation générale du
volet santé du projet de loi des
finances de
159,44%. avant tout nous tenons à
rappeler que d'après le collectif nos
services publics le budget de l'État
pour 2023 et le deuxième budget le plus
austéritaire pour les services publics
ces 20 dernières années ce budget
présenté comme ambitieux et pourtant
très loin de couvrir l'augmentation des
dépenses nécessaires dues à l'inflation
vous annoncez aussi une augmentation de
1,58% des crédits à louer au programme
prévention sécurité sanitaire et offre
de soins nous tenons à souligner que
cette homone de 1,58% est un trompe
l'oeil qui cache la réduction constante
du budget du programme 204 il a été
divisé par trois depuis 8 ans en passant
de 630 millions d'euros de crédit à
louer en 2014 à 212 millions pour 2023
de plus vous avez déclaré vouloir mettre
la prévention et l'éducation pour la
santé je cite au cœur des politiques du
programme pourtant nous pouvons
constater que la prévention ne
représente que 6% du budget total pour
le volet santé de la proposition de loi
des finances
vous reconnaissez vous-même que notre
système de santé devra ainsi faire face
à des mutations profondes alors qu'en
est-il de la baisse de 2 millions
d'euros dans le pilotage de la politique
de santé publique comment voulez-vous
faire de la prévention une priorité
lorsque vous coupez encore plus les
vivre aux associations de terrain qui
font un travail essentiel sur les
questions de santé sexuelle ou de
prévention des addictions notamment nous
rappelons ici que plus de 130 centres
pratiquants l'avortement ont fermé en 15
ans la prévention en matière de santé
sexuelle est donc déjà sous-financée 2
millions d'euros de moins dans le
pilotage de la politique de santé
publique c'est aussi 2 millions d'euros
de moins dans la promotion de la santé
mentale
les cas d’anxiété de dépression sont
pourtant en hausse de 25% dans le monde
depuis la pandémie en particulier chez
les jeunes et les femmes aussi nous ne
pouvons que regretter que les crédits du
volley santé des populations stagne et
n'occupent que 0,03% du budget total
pour le volet santé les besoins sont
pourtant bel et bien là prenons par
exemple les départements d'outre-mer ou
la santé périnatale s'est constamment
dégradée ces dernières années alors
qu'elle est censée constituer l'une des
priorités de votre budget en matière de
prévention
l'Inserm m'a aussi montré en évidence la
présence de particules fines dès la
grossesse dans les organes de fœtus
donc bien avant de venir au monde nous
sommes donc d'ores et déjà contaminé
et votre budget est une preuve de plus
des œillères carbore le gouvernement
quant à la Pâque catastrophique de la
pollution sur la santé des citoyens et
des citoyens
le rapport sur l'impact environnemental
du budget de l'État pour 2023 vient
d'être publié et le constat est sans
appel pour le volet santé seul 1% du
budget et dédié au financement d'action
dans le domaine de la santé et de
l'environnement
1% 1% c'est le niveau d'engagement de
votre gouvernement sur les questions
d'impact du changement climatique sur la
santé des Françaises et des Français
vous ne prenez au sérieux la question
qu'à un seul pour cent
comment ne pas émettre de sérieux doutes
sur votre engagement pour la santé
environnementale alors que vous prévoyez
une baisse drastique de 10% des dépenses
d'intervention soit 13 millions d'euros
ce poste du budget finance pourtant
directement les organismes chargés de
mener les études et de mettre en place
des politiques en matière de santé
d'environnement coupez une fois de plus
dans les budgets de la santé c'est
prendre le risque d'invisabiliser
davantage un phénomène qui est déjà là
celui de la destruction de notre
écosystème qui détruit aussi notre santé
vous revendiquez vous inscrire dans la
lignée de l'objectif one house santé
globale de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
j'entends donc que vous êtes au fait du
constat de l'OMS selon lequel
l'augmentation des maladies chroniques
est directement liée aux facteurs
environnementaux ainsi qu'à nos modes de
vie les symptômes sont connus problème
respiratoires dû à la pollution de l'air
affection générée par les perdures
perturbateurs endocriniens trouble et
pathologies liée à l'exposition et à des
pollutions pardon toxiques
investir dans une politique de
prévention en santé environnementale
c'est pourtant réduire à terme le coût
social et sanitaire du bruit par exemple
qui s'élève chaque année après de 155
milliards d'euros celui de la pollution
de l'air entre 70 et 100 milliards
d'euros par an celui de la malbouffe
après de 50 milliards d'euros ou encore
celui du mal logement après de 30
milliards d'euros nous rappelons donc au
gouvernement qu'on ne peut prétendre
faire de la santé des Françaises et des
Français une priorité d'action si les
enjeux environnementaux se cantonnent à
des demi mesures et si le gouvernement
poursuit son entreprise de désengagement
de l'État dans le domaine de la santé
le budget qui symbolise l'engagement
concret du gouvernement au-delà des
grands discours ne peut faire moins
basse sur la prise en compte des
inégalités sociales et les injustices
climatiques qui frappent les plus
vulnérables d'entre nous
[Rires]
[Musique]
évidemment le budget de la santé
publique et pour l'essentiel ailleurs
que dans ces lignes budgétaires même si
elles contiennent des actions
importantes je dis au passage y compris
en dialogue avec notre collègue Val tout
que ça pose un problème et le problème
de la maîtrise du Parlement sur ces
politiques publiques et la manière dont
elles sont mises en œuvre
bon toutes les études confirment que
l'espérance de vie varie en fonction de
la classe sociale donc on a un véritable
défi de réduction des inégalités
territoriales et sociales de santé
auquel il faut s'attaquer de manière
vigoureuse et en réalité le diagnostic
ne change pas beaucoup d'années en année
il faut quand même en faire le constat
donc ça veut dire que les actions que
nous menons en la matière soit sont
inefficaces soit sont ainsi suffisantes
soit les deux
je voudrais dire un mot sur la nécessité
que nous avons d'agir sur nos modes de
vie sur nos modes de production nos
modes de consommation et donc ça suppose
d'élever le niveau de conscience des
difficultés auxquelles nous devons faire
face et déniver le niveau de conscience
sanitaire j'avais évoqué leur du
précédent avis budgétaire la question de
la pollution atmosphérique j'en fais en
quelques mots un exemple il se trouve
que santé publique France avait estimé à
40 villes le nombre de décès annuel dû à
l'exposition aux particules fines entre
2016 et 2019 en France et que selon
l'OMS la pollution de l'air et la
première cause de décès liée à
l'environnement avec 7 millions de morts
chaque année dans le monde on est en
face d'un défi considérable j'y suis
confronté dans mon territoire mais je
sais que c'est sans doute notre cas aux
uns et aux autres mais je pense y être
confronté de manière singulière
particulière j'avais formulé des
propositions madame la ministre celle de
créer un délégué interministériel à la
lutte contre la pollution atmosphérique
et j'ai fait sur la santé celle de créer
des territoires pilotes dans la lutte
contre les pollutions atmosphériques et
je crois que nous avons besoin de
prendre des initiatives d'expérimenter
et d'être d'avoir une une volonté
politique en réalité un peu plus
vigoureuse que je ne ressens pas dans le
document qui nous est présenté pas plus
cette année en vérité que que l'année
dernière
je veux dire quelques mots également sur
l'aide médicale d'État le budget qui est
en augmentation de 12% après quand même
un peu de compression et notamment des
restrictions en 2020 sur l'aide médicale
d'État elle-même il représente 0,5% au
total des dépenses de santé je crois que
c'est à la fois un geste d'élémentaires
humanité et un geste élémentaire pour
l'humanité que de garantir l'accès aux
soins à chacune à chacun quel que soit
sa situation administrative et quel que
soit ses moyens et je pense que notre
pays peut s'enorgueillir même si c'est à
mon sens assez normal que nous soyons
nous fassions ce choix politique
un rebours d'un certain égoïsme que j'ai
entendu pointé ça et là la santé est un
bien commun mondial et je rappelle
d'ailleurs pour mémoire que
la
les actes médicaux sont y compris sur
notre territoire pratiqué pour beaucoup
par des médecins étrangers en tout cas
pour partie
je voudrais également évoquer l'Inca et
la stagnation des crédits de l'Inca y
compris la stagnation du plafond
d'emploi et je pense que nous devrions
contenus de ce que nous voyons
l'augmentation des des cancers donnés
plus de moyens à cette à cet organisme
qui je crois ne doit pas y compris
d'ailleurs avec cette stagnation ils
vont subir de plein fouet
l'inflation avec un plafond d'emploi qui
est qui demeure je sais pas où est-ce
qu'ils vont trouver l'argent sans doute
sur les crédits des recherches qu'ils
vont conduire je pense que ça va poser
un problème je voulais vous interroger
sur le FIVA madame la ministre vérifiez
que la fusion avec toniam est bien aband
et vous demandez si la récente étude de
lances qui établit un lien causal avéré
entre le l'amiante et le cancer des
ovaires et du larynx sera des effets
potentiellement sur sur le FIFA en tout
cas j'en ai pas trouvé trace dans dans
le document enfin je voudrais conclure
en vous parlant du volley médico-social
du Ségur 1,25 milliards d'euros si je me
trompe pas millions d'euros peut-être
milliards d'euros pardon donc avec une
question sur la répartition territoriale
mais aussi sur la répartition entre
différents types d'établissements très
clairement escort pa risque de toucher
des subsides de ce point de vue là
madame la ministre
merci bien je vais à présent donner la
parole à Madame la Ministre et Monsieur
le Député encore une fois je m'excuse
madame la ministre cher Agnès vous avez
la parole
merci
pour vos nombreuses questions vos
nombreuses questions à la fois dans le
sujet et
beaucoup pas dans le sujet donc je vais
essayer je vais essayer je vais essayer
de répondre un maximum d'entre elles
même parfois lorsqu'elles étaient hors
sujets
donc nous sommes bien dans le cadre de
discussion sur la mission santé du PLF
sur la me merci Monsieur d'arrivée de
l'avoir rappelé que la me a un objectif
humanitaire et je crois que comme vous
l'avez dit notre pays peut se nourrir de
pouvoir maintenir
un objectif de soins de personnes
étrangères arrivant sur notre territoire
vous avez rappelé que ce budget
représente 0,5% de la dépense de
l'assurance maladie mais que évidemment
depuis plusieurs années notamment depuis
2020 nous avons réformé j'allais dire le
panier de soins ça a été quelque chose
qui a été partagé et qui était construit
sur ces bancs nous avons renforcé aussi
les contrôles
et je le répète ce poids de la dépense
représente 0,5 % des dépenses de
l'assurance maladie avec un objectif à
la fois humanitaire et un objectif
sanitaire
sur l'incar sur l'incar rappelait que le
l'Inca est cofinancé à la fois via la
mission PLF mais aussi vient la mission
le ministère de l'Enseignement supérieur
et de la Recherche c'est un
cofinancement sur la stratégie décennale
nous pouvons constater que malgré tout
le budget a augmenté de 20% par rapport
au précédent plan cancer en lien bien
sûr avec et vous l'avez souligné la
nécessité de pouvoir mieux accompagner
la recherche sur le domaine de la
recherche sur le cancer le maintien des
plafonds d'emploi effectivement est
stables depuis trois ans
sur la prévention chère à vous tous et
notamment à notre collègue Cyril qui a
défendu son jaune budgétaire je me
souviens de nombreuses discussions qui a
eu raison de rappeler que la prévention
c'est 3 milliards de l'État mais il y a
des collectivités un milliard de
l'assurance maladie
je le redis parce que parce qu'il est
important de souligner que la prévention
est un enjeu majeur et que pour la
première fois nous avons un ministère de
la Santé s'appelle un ministère de la
santé et de la prévention nous sommes
ici dans les premiers budgets présentés
par ce gouvernement et d'ores et déjà
vous avez pu constater que les mesures
sont annoncées dans le pdfss notamment
avec les trois bilans prévention aux
âges de la vie enfin 25 40-45 60 65 que
les enjeux en termes
faut que je retrouve mes fiches c'est là
le problème c'est que quand il y a
beaucoup de questions il y a beaucoup de
fiches
que les enjeux en termes de nouveautés
de prévention qu'on porte des mesures
nouvelles la mise en oeuvre du plan
corps déconne la mise en oeuvre du Plan
Santé Environnement la mise en oeuvre de
la stratégie nationale de l'alimentation
de la nutrition et du climat la
réalisation d'une étude individuelle
nationale des consommations alimentaires
la lutte contre l'antibiorésistance des
moyens complémentaires prévus pour
financer les systèmes d'information une
provision au titre de la gestion des
sujets de crise sanitaire et pour
landeces un opérateur de l'état de
nouveaux moyens pour réaliser des
missions notamment la participation
l'organisation des événements sportifs
notamment la Coupe du monde de rugby il
faut le signaler le transfert de
compétences en manière de cosmétique et
de vos renforcement des moyens en toxico
vigilance ce sont quand même 13 millions
d'euros qui seront consacrés à ces
nouvelles mesures
la santé environnementale est un enjeu
important et vous l'avez tous souligné
ce ce plan est doté de mesures si je
retrouve ma fiche je vais vous les
donner
je vais vous les donner quand j'aurai
retrouvé ma fiche
qui doit être quelque part par là
papa
concernant le covidon
c'est un sujet dans lequel nous avons
beaucoup travaillé lors de la dernière
stature monsieur Juvin et que le travail
en cours sur la stratégie nationale
nous avons collectivement besoin
d'enrichir les connaissances médicales
et la recherche sur ce sujet mais c'est
un sujet qui est bien pris en compte sur
le Ségur numérique évoqué par Monsieur
hussard Maxime nous avons 2 milliards
d'euros qui sont consacrés à la
transformation du numérique dont 0,5
milliards de SMS et 0,5 milliards de
rattrapage du numérique en établissement
c'est un enjeu majeur pour
pour nous tous je crois que j'ai répondu
sur les questions concernant je partage
l'idée de la plus réanualité je crois
que c'est un sujet que nous avons
beaucoup beaucoup évoqué et c'est un
sujet voilà qui a été prise en cours
notamment puisque nous avons maintenant
des perspectives à 3 ans grâce à la loi
votée par proposé par notre collègue
Thomas Meunier
sur le FS là aussi
sur le l'Établissement français du sang
nous avons je rencontrerai très
prochainement les dirigeants de l'EFS
nous avons un véritable enjeu j'allais
dire là aussi de professionnels de santé
pour pouvoir assurer j'allais dire les
prélèvements et la promotion de du don
du sang
c'est un enjeu de santé majeur et
notamment notamment sur les périodes
d'été les campagnes de promotion sont
essentielles
nous avons aussi évoqué peut-être le
manque de lisibilité de toutes ces
campagnes de promotion de la prévention
et moi je pense que le fait que le
ministère de la Santé et de la
progression existe va nous permettre de
pouvoir j'allais dire rationaliser et
rassembler tout ça sous une même
bannière pour que les campagnes de
prévention soient effectivement plus
lisible
je crois avoir répondu sur les sujets
qui concernent la mission santé en tant
que telle sur les sujets qui ne
concernaient pas la mission santé et ils
ont été nombreux
rappeler aux personnes qui ont députés
je crois qu'il est évoqué les sujets sur
l'ondament vous rappelez que Londres
pour le projet de loi de finances 2023
et de 3,7 et qu'il est de 4,1
concernant
l'hôpital
que les fermetures de lit évoquaient
pour parfois par manque de soignants
mais aussi pour vous rappeler que nous
avons un système de santé qui évolue et
la transformation de des soins
ambulatoires et l'attractivité des
métiers permettent aussi de faire
évoluer la prise en charge à l'hôpital
voilà je crois que c'est Monsieur Juvin
qui a évoqué
les enjeux de tarification et des
mesures suite aux mesures d'urgence de
la mission aubrône vous rappelez que
cette mission est un cours d'évaluation
que les rapports d'évaluation seront
présentés à au comité d'évaluation qui a
été suivi en direct là aussi c'est une
nouvelle méthode puisque l'évaluation de
cette mission a été
réalisée en temps réel et que c'est
terminé le 30 septembre que le rapport
sera présenté dans les jours à venir et
que les
les actions qui ont fonctionné seront
gardées comme ça a été évoqués celle qui
ont donné nos papillotes mises en oeuvre
parce que des mesures d'urgence prises
en cours d'été mais dont nous pensons
qu'elles doivent pouvoir être maintenu
le seront et celles qui n'ont pas de
tout donner satisfaction qui nous pas
fonctionné seront aband
je vous le redis les résultats de cette
évaluation seront
seront portées à connaissance de
au comité de suivi dans les jours à
venir pour répondre à Monsieur darivine
sur la fusion FIVA oniam la réponse est
non enfin oui enfin vous avez compris ce
que je veux dire dans ce qu'on prend
tous les deux on a l'habitude
[Musique]
voilà
que bien sûr sur la santé
environnementale
l'enjeu de la qualité de l'air est un
vrai enjeu et que vous savez que le CNR
en santé va bientôt arriver dans vos
régions et que si vous avez envie de
porter des expérimentations n'hésitez
pas à aller discuter au CNR et que si
les actions peuvent être expérimentées
dans vos territoires et en ce qui
concerne l'enjeu de santé
environnementale
pourquoi pas monsieur dareville
sur les questions qui ne concernaient
pas tout à fait notre notre mission et
notre sujet du soir
concernant le la fin de vie
le président de la République suite à la
vie du CCSE a souhaité ouvrir le débat
sur la fin de vie tout d'abord souligner
que c'est la première fois qu'un
président de la République ouvre un
débat sur ce sujet qui est un vrai sujet
de société il a souhaité le faire à la
fois via une concession une consultation
citoyenne et vient une mission qu'il a
confié à deux membres du gouvernement
Olivier Véran et moi-même nous
travaillerons à la fois avec un groupe
transpartisan de parlementaires députés
et sénateurs avec des soignants
qui sont favorables ou pas des soignants
mais pas que des médecins parce que je
pense qu'il est important sur ce sujet
de prendre en compte tous les soignants
madame la Présidente va lancer bientôt
mission d'évaluation de la loi kless
Leonetti
nous travaillerons aussi sur la
constitution d'un lexique parce qu'il
est important que nous parlions tous de
la même chose et que nous puissions
donner j'allais dire la même définition
homo
et ses travaux vont être lancés assez
assez rapidement au cours en ce qui
concerne Olivier Véran et moi-même dans
les dans les jours à venir et à la
consultation aussi Cayenne qui sera
effectuée en région via le Césaire sera
lancée
au début décembre de mémoire
l'idée étant bien sûr que nous puissions
collectivement avoir un débat apaisé sur
un sujet de société nos concitoyens
attendent ce débat je pense qu'il est
important que nous puissions au débattre
sur la question couvre la vie du CCNE la
liberté de choisir sa fin de vie mais
que le Président de la République a été
aussi est la première ministre ont été
très clairs sur la feuille de route qui
est la nôtre c'est bien sûr de
travailler aussi sur les soins
palliatifs je crois que l'occasion
d'ouvrir ce débat nous permet et nous
donne l'opportunité de pouvoir accélérer
encore plus vite sur les soins
palliatifs vous l'avez rappelé 23
départements n'ont toujours pas de
centre 23 donc toujours pas de de soins
de soins palliatifs mais outre le fait
d'inégalité d'accès il y a aussi un
grand enjeu de formation des
professionnels soignants qu'ils soient
médecins qu'ils soient infirmiers qu'ils
soient aide-soignante qu'il soit aide à
domicile puisque l'enjeu de la prise en
charge à domicile de son poliative et
quelque chose d'important nous avons un
sujet d'information de nos concitoyens
sur ce que sont les soins palliatifs et
sur les sur les directives anticipées
seul 18% de nos concitoyens de plus de
50 ans ont inscrit une directive
anticipée et puis nous pourrons à
l'occasion de l'ouverture de ce débat
sur j'allais dire notre rapport à la
mort
avoir une réflexion aussi sur les enjeux
de l'accompagnement des aidants à la fin
de vie et peut-être se poser la question
de l'accompagnement du deuil et puis
peut-être aussi avoir des réflexions sur
ce qui nous est arrivé pendant la crise
sanitaire où nous avons été confrontés
de près ou de loin à des personnes qui
sont décédées seules à l'hôpital en
EHPAD ou à domicile qui sont partis
seuls parce que nous étions face à un
virus que nous ne connaissions pas
est-ce que nous avons des conclusions
des solutions à apporter pour que ça
n'arrive plus si jamais nous étions de
nouveau confrontés à cette situation
donc le président devrait République a
souhaité ouvrir ce débat et nous allons
y travailler ensemble à la fois les
citoyens à la fois les parlementaires à
la fois les soignants pour apporter
apporter des réflexions et le président
de la République avec les livrables qui
lui seront fournis pourra prendre sa
décision sur le sujet des déserts
médicaux vous avez raison il est urgent
d'agir et d'apporter réponse c'est le
quotidien qui est celui du ministère à
la fois de François Brown et le mien
nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir à
travers le PLFSS mais vous dire et comme
la souligner
Frédéric Valletoux ça paraît pas grand
chose mais je peux vous assure je peux
vous assurer que c'est énorme ce que les
ordres et les sept ordres ont signé
mercredi vendredi dernier c'est une
avancée majeure d'abord dans la méthode
c'est à dire que les professionnels de
santé ont bien pris conscience qu'il
était aussi important d'apporter des
réponses et d'accompagner à la fois le
gouvernement mais aussi les
collectivités territoriales sur le sujet
de réponse aux besoins de santé et nous
travaillons maintenant avec toutes ces
professions pour j'allais dire décliner
le fait que les médecins qui restent
j'allais dire l'acteur majeur puisse
travailler avec les autres professions
de santé pour répondre aux besoins de
santé de nos concitoyens et notamment
aussi millions de nos concitoyens qui
n'ont pas de médecin traitant et aussi
157 000 qui sont patients sous LD qui
n'ont pas de médecin traitant les les
règles sont posées nous avançons
et nous avançons
plutôt de façon sereine et nous avons
sont plutôt bien
merci bien Madame la Ministre donc nous
allons poursuivre avec les questions des
députés il y en a 12 une minute par
question donc je vais vous demander
d'être très concis d'autant plus que
nous avons 30 amendements à examiner
donc je vais demander également à la
ministre après d'être concise allez
Monsieur Jean-François Rousset vous avez
la parole merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre le projet annuel de
performance du programme 204 prévention
sécurité sanitaire et offre de soins
indique je cite le recours numérique est
un vecteur d'évolution structurel de
notre système de santé aussi comme vous
je crois que la télémédecine est un
formidable outil qu'il faut développer
notamment dans les territoires où
l'offre de soins est insuffisante en
veillant bien sûr à ce que la qualité et
la sécurité des soins sont assurées
c'est le sens des amendements que je
porte dans le cas du PLFSS en
particulier je pense qu'il faut
encourager davantage la télé-expertise
qui permet un professionnel de santé de
sol
à distance la vie médicale d'un ou
plusieurs de ses collègues aujourd'hui
la convention médicale limite l'usage de
la télémédecine à 20% de l'activité
conventionnée des médecins libéraux sans
distinguer sur financement telle
expertise et téléconsultation or la
télépertise facilite l'exercice
professionnel coordonnée et ne devrait
pas selon moi être intégré dans ce
plafond de 20%. aussi madame la ministre
que pensez-vous faire pour développer la
télémédecine je vous remercie très bien
merci monsieur le député Monsieur Victor
Catteau vous avez la parole merci Madame
à la présidente madame la ministre dans
le projet de loi de finances que vous
nous présentez pour l'année 2023 un
élément manifestement criant et
l'immense incohérence présente dans la
répartition des crédits budgétaires
alloués à la mission santé en effet en
augmentant de plus de 133 millions
d'euros cette tête visant à prendre en
charge l'intégralité des dépenses
médicales les étrangers résidents de
façon irrégulière sur le sol français et
qui s'élève un total de 1,2 milliards
d'euros le gouvernement exprime
clairement sa volonté de garantir
éperdument la continuation si ce n'est
l'accélé du processus d'injustice
sociale et maintenant de l'État il est
d'ailleurs important de noter que cette
hausse de plus de 12% des crédits
alloués à l'AME par rapport à l'année
précédente et supérieure à celle de
l'ensemble des crédits destinés à la
mission santé si par élégant je vous
épargnerai la remise en cause du bien
fondé de ce dispositif il est néanmoins
évident que la disproportion des crédits
qui lui sont attribués tout simplement
ahurissant notamment en comparaison des
autres lignes budgétaires ces lignes de
crédit budgétaire telles que la
modernisation de l'offre de soins ou
encore la prévention des maladies
chroniques de la qualité de vie des
malades crédits que vous refusez
d'augmenter davantage d'augmenter tout
court son source chez le compatriote
d'un immense d'une immense
incompréhension ainsi et par conséquent
ma question est comment expliquer cette
incohérence des décisions politiques
privilégies concernant les autres plutôt
que les nôtres merci Madame Fanta
Beretti vous avez la parole madame la
ministre madame la Présidente chers
collègues 20% des étudiants vivent sous
le seuil de pauvreté la paupérisation a
de nombreux impacts notamment
alimentaires de réussite scolaire de
relation sociale mais aussi d'accès aux
soins dans une étude menée auprès de 7
les jeunes franciliens ayant bénéficié
des services de Linky une association
parisienne fournit qui fournit de l'aide
alimentaire aux étudiants plus d'un
jeune sur deux dispose d'un reste à
vivre inférieur à 50 euros par mois et
un sur deux à renoncer à des soins au
cours des derniers mois pour des raisons
financières depuis le début du
quinquennat le gouvernement est
multiplié les dispositifs de soutien
financier destiné à préserver le pouvoir
d'achat des étudiants sur le logement et
la restauration sur le champ de la santé
également vous avez par exemple renforcé
la coopération entre les acteurs de
l'enseignement supérieur et de
l'assurance maladie avec la désignation
de référents enseignement supérieur ou
encore développé santé psy étudiant
cependant dans un contexte d'inflation
galopante et alors que le coût de la vie
ne cesse d'augmenter le renoncement en
soins de nos jeunes est un enjeu majeur
merci madame la députée merci
la parole est à Monsieur Serge Müller
non une minute une minute c'est pas
possible
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues alors que
vous prévoyez la gratuité de la pilule
du lendemain ainsi que le dépistage
gratuit des IST dans le PLFSS je ne vois
rien concernant les politiques de
prévention de ces infections dans les
années 80 la prévention contre le sida
passée par la promotion du préservatif
cela a marqué toute une génération et ça
ça s'est avéré être très efficace
aujourd'hui nous faisons face à une
augmentation des IST notamment les
chlamydia et les gonocoques ce qui
montre que les jeunes sont moins alertés
sur l'usage du préservatif monsieur
Brown l'a reconnu récemment il nous
indiquait en effet que nous sommes en
dessous des budgets européens en matière
de prévention il représente 4% du budget
santé chez nos voisins européens contre
2% chez nous monsieur Brown a dit qu'il
était optimiste quant au futur politique
de prévention pouvez-vous donc nous les
décrire de façon concrète et pouvez-vous
également nous dire quand vous souhaitez
vous mettre en place la gratuité des
préservatif je vous remercie merci bien
la parole est à Michel perron
oui madame la ministre madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur je
souhaiterais vous interroger madame la
ministre au sujet d'une problématique
qui relève de la mission santé et
notamment du programme de 104 action 14
l'usage addictif du camseix
ce sont des pratiques émergentes
notamment chez les jeunes et en grande
augmentation depuis quelques années qui
consiste à l'utilisation de produits
psychoactifs durant les rapports sexuels
c'est pratique vont font prendre aux
usagers des risques multiples et
importants forte dépendance et addiction
aux drogues sur dose mortels et non
maîtrise de la consommation transmission
d'istes ou du VIH des sociabilisation et
troubles de la santé mentale par exemple
ça fait beaucoup face à cette situation
le ministre Olivier Véran commandait en
septembre 2021 un rapport à ce sujet au
professeur amine Benyamina afin de
dresser un état des lieux de la
situation et de formuler plusieurs
recommandations afin d'agir sur la
prévention et la réduction des risques
ainsi je souhaiterais connaître la
feuille de route du gouvernement madame
la ministre à ce sujet merci
la feuille de route merci bien je suis
obligé d'accélérer sinon on ne finira
pas Jean-Luc [__] vous avez la parole
madame ou lors de votre passage à La
Réunion dernièrement vous avez annoncé
la tenue d'un conseil national de la
refondation avec qui est-ce que
l'outre-mer est consulté sur la question
du coefficient géographique le président
Macron s'était engagé de la revaloriser
vous avez dit qu'une étude est toujours
en cours étudiée pour pourquoi encore
quand allez-vous tenir parole et
revaloriser ce coefficient heureux
qu'est-ce que cela sera fait en 2023 par
ailleurs selon une récente étude de
l'Insee le nombre de décès honnêtement
augmenté en 2020 690 de plus à la
Réunion unos une hausse qui résulte
selon l'institut vieillissement de la
population ce vieillissement implique
une nouvelle politique efficace quel
sera elle notamment dans la construction
des EHPAD et le maintien à domicile
enfin la santé mentale est un secteur
particulièrement touché à la Réunion
dans un rapport il est fait état d'une
sous dotation de 20% inférieur à celle
de la métropole des engagements ont été
pris pour l'ouverture d'une clinique
psychiatrique dans l'est de la Réunion
va-t-elle voir vraiment le jour et quand
merci bien la parole est à Didier Martin
je vous donne le micro allez-y monsieur
le député merci madame la Présidente
bonsoir madame la ministre heureux de
vous retrouver dans cette enceinte notre
commission vous avez assez longuement
développé la question de la fin de vie
et je vous en remercie dans ce dans
cette mission
la question de des maladies chroniques
et de la qualité de vie des malades peut
également interpeller le rôle des
pouvoirs publics par rapport aux
associations celle qui effectivement
sont au service de ces malades en fin de
vie pour les accompagner pour les
informer sur la question des directives
anticipées sur la question de désigner
une personne de confiance je vous
demande très simplement comment vous
voyez que en complément des unités de
soins palliatifs bien entendu c'est en
travail commun avec elle comment ces
associations peuvent être soutenues par
l'action 14 du programme 204 je vous
remercie
merci bien monsieur le député Monsieur
Joël laviranier
merci Madame Madame la Ministre délégué
la pandémie et le confinement banalisent
les troubles psychiques je ne
concitoyens et notamment chez nos jeunes
le gouvernement a tenté d'y répondre via
mon psy un dispositif mal pensé mal
appliqué qui n'a pas eu le succès à
escompté depuis des années la
psychiatrie le parent port de l'hôpital
public alors même que chacun d'entre
nous connaît la situation globale des
hôpitaux ces deux sujets forment tout
que l'on peut appeler la santé mentale
et malheureusement nos politiques
publiques continuent de considérer que
la santé mentale est moins importante
que la santé physique malgré tous les
signaux rien n'est fait il n'y a
toujours pas de plat pour refonder la
santé mentale à l'horizon le coup annuel
direct indirect des troubles si
psychiques est estimés à 109 milliards
d'euros dans le même temps les dépenses
annuelles de santé mentale ne sont que
de 23 milliards d'euros alors allez-vous
agir pour que la santé mentale soit
mieux considérée à et traiter sinon elle
te vous disposez engager un travail sur
ce sujet essentiel je vous remercie
merci bien la parole est à Yannick
neuder
si je le prends merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre trois
petites réactions dans l'ombre de ce
débat un peu accéléré avant un 49-3 le
premier sur les faits volumes attention
quand même sur les 159 % d'augmentation
puisque les 1 milliard 930 000 sont
quand même des financements européens du
plan de relance sur les sujets qui sont
considérés dans le sujet justement on
vous a signifié l'augmentation de la
mortalité infantile on voit que le
budget santé mère enfant reste identique
on vous a signifié effectivement pas
d'évolution budgétaire pour la santé
mentale et somme toute de le rappeler
comme Philippe juin l'a dit il n'y a
rien sur le covid long contrairement à
d'autres pays européens et sur ce qui
est du soi-disant hors sujet je trouve
quand même étonnant que l'on est quand
même une satisfaction à avoir un Honda
ma 4,1 qui est en dessous de l'inflation
et d'avoir une valeur de la mission
Braun d'évaluation au 30 septembre que
vaut cette évaluation sur des mesures
qui ont commencé début juillet qui vont
être évalués en septembre je me pose la
question merci bien monsieur le député
madame Annie Vidal
le
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre la mission santé a parmi ces
objectifs l'organisation d'une offre de
soins adaptée à nos territoires afin de
réduire les inégalités dans l'accès aux
soins et par ailleurs la crise covid a
fait émergée de nombreuses initiatives
de terrain très intéressantes parmi
celles-ci l'unité de renfort de
Gournay-en-Bray dans ma circonscription
a fait ses preuves grâce à une
adaptation très rapide face à la crise
sanitaire pour aller vers les personnes
les plus éloignées cela a été possible
grâce à la collaboration d'un médecin et
d'infirmières aux compétences élargies
des infirmières de premier recours qui
constitue sur le territoire un
renforcement de l'offre de soins de
première ligne toutefois en l'état
actuel le cadre légal ne correspond pas
à ces nouveaux modes d'exercice ma
question est simple madame la ministre
seriez-vous favorable au soutien de ces
pratiques qui permettent de mieux faire
face à la pénurie d'offre de soins sur
nos territoires et de faire bénéficier
les patients de ces acteurs de soins
capables de réaliser la mission de
consultation ambulatoire de premier je
vous remercie merci bien monsieur Arthur
Delaporte
c'est une épidémie madame la Présidente
merci on a en effet une hausse en trompe
l'oeil des crédits de la mission santé
de 159 % qui est largement dû on a
évoqué à la création d'un programme
temporaire je vais m'attarder sur un
point très rapidement qui est la
question de l'Ame qui hack finalement un
rattrapage puisqu'on avait une stabilité
en 2020 et 2021
et donc pour dénoncer finalement à
travers cette ce programme 183 la dérive
morale et sanitaire de la réforme de
2020 qui se traduit aujourd'hui par un
renforcement de la traque des
bénéficiaires des contrôles qui visent
des allocataires de l'Ame puisque en
insistant sur les contrôles vous
remettez une pièce dans la machine de la
réforme de 2020 qui a été tant décrié
par les associations qui évoquaient une
triple faute morale économique et
sanitaire par conséquent il faut
absolument stopper ce discours et nous
vous y invitons frontalement parce que
nous réponds pas accepter ce type de
mesure
très bien la parole est Madame jossonnet
n'est pas là donc c'est Madame Corneloup
et ensuite madame Thévenot merci madame
la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur le programme 204
finance aussi le dispositif
d'indemnisation des victimes de la
dépakine il y a 3 ans nous avons adopté
une réforme de ce dispositif à la
demande de ma collègue Véronique louvagi
rapporteur spécial de la commission des
finances cette réforme devait notamment
permettre de réduire de trois mois à un
mois le délai est indemnisation des
victimes par l'ONEM toutefois son
application a bien évidemment été
retardée du fait de la crise sanitaire
et il est dès lors difficile d'en
établir un bilan complet en tout cas
nous voyons que la trajectoire demeure
toujours très éloignée des objectifs
initiaux puisque le financement de ce
dispositif baisse une nouvelle fois de
10 millions d'euros en raison d'une
sous-consommation quelle piste pourrait
être envisagée pour atteindre les
objectifs fixés merci
très bien Madame Thévenoud
gros merci je vais elle est très vite la
question est très simple la volonté de
faire émerger une véritable culture de
la prévention est un point indédiable et
que nous saluons ici tant il a souvent
et longtemps été oublié mais quand on
dit prévention nous devons aussi dire
communication parce qu'une prévention
sans communication ne sert à rien
notamment au plus près des acteurs des
acteurs médicaux sur les territoires
ainsi ma question est très rapide que
compte faire le gouvernement pour que
cette communication soit effective tant
sur le plan national que auprès de nos
acteurs de soins et de nos territoires
merci merci bien et bien après ces
nombreuses questions madame la ministre
vous avez la parole pour des éléments de
réponse
tout en étant synthétique
la présidente ne change pas je vous
rassure
pour répondre sur les questions de télé
médecine et télé expertise d'abord vous
répondre que le chiffre de 20% était
dans les négociations conventionnelles
que la télémédecine et la télépertise
sont en plein développement et que nul
doute qu'à l'heure où nous allons
repartir sur des négociations
conventionnelles ce sera le peut-être
l'occasion de revoir ses règles
néanmoins il faudra aussi faire face à
deux sujets tout d'abord la
téléconsultation utilisée par des
spécialistes qui n'ont pas forcément
besoin d'examen clinique ou quand même
de temps en temps voir le patient c'est
bien
voilà je pense qu'il faut aussi établir
des règles et rappeler malgré tout que
pour les patients qui les médecins qui
utilisent la téléconsultation ce chiffre
n'est que de 3% et qu'il y a un gros
Delta entre les les médecins qui
pratiquent de l'examen clinique et ce
dont la spécialité ne ne nécessite pas
mais néanmoins revoir ses enjeux à
l'ordre des négociations
conventionnelles semble important je sur
la me je pas je crois que j'ai répondu
très clairement sur la première partie
madame Beretti concernant le la santé
des étudiants vous avez raison de poser
la question c'est un enjeu un enjeu
majeur
rappelait que la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur a annoncé il y
a pas très longtemps que le service de
santé universitaire allait le Service de
santé des étudiants je crois que c'est
important qu'un budget
de 8,2 millions d'euros supplémentaires
il sera consacré et que l'objectif de
prévention pourra être aussi concernant
les étudiants vu dans le bilan de
prévention consacrée à l'âge de 20-25
ans
concernant les les questions sur la
santé sexuelle d'abord vous rappeler que
le préservatif peut être pris en charge
sur prescription puisqu'il est remboursé
ça fait maintenant je crois trois ans
mais enfin ça fait moins maintenant
quelques années que le préservatif
lorsqu'il est prescrit et pris en charge
j'étais une mesure
qui avait été ici voté que l'enjeu
l'enjeu de la prévention concernant
concernant les l'accès à la
contraception et la prévention des IST
est un enjeu majeur ce sera sans doute
là aussi en ce qui concerne le bilan des
20-25 ans quelque chose qui pourra et
qui devra être évoqué à cette occasion
là vous rappelez que le Cid est un
endroit aussi où les enjeux de
prévention sont évoqués pour toutes les
personnes qui peuvent s'y rendre de
façon complètement anonyme et que la
contraception gratuite dans le palais
FSS pour les jeunes femmes depuis 25 ans
sur
la Réunion monsieur ratonon toujours là
monsieur ratonon vous dire que
effectivement j'ai effectué un très beau
déplacement à la Réunion j'y ai vu
beaucoup de belles choses
en termes de prévention en termes de
violence faites aux femmes sur le
coefficient géographique j'avais pu
apporter et dire que la réponse était
que
l'étude était en cours elle est toujours
par les services de l'adresse
sur la nécessité de ou pas de revoir ce
coefficient géographique qui concerne
spécifiquement la Réunion Monsieur
Martin sur les associations et l'enjeu
des directives anticipées et des
personnes de confiance c'est un débat
que nous aurons lorsque le débat sur la
fin de vie sera sera ouvert mais bien
sûr que toutes les associations
auront leur part apprendre et d'ailleurs
nous souhaitons qu'elle puisse prendre
part au débat
sur la feuille de route santé mentale
vous savez que il est plus là
il est plus là
voilà sur l'augmentation de
des crédits de 159% évoqué par certains
qui seraient en trompe l'oeil puisque
nous intégrons le 379 je vais redire que
très clairement si nous retirons le 379
qui est un jeu d'écriture
la mission santé voit ses crédits
augmenter de 4,2 % donc il faut on peut
aussi le dire on peut aussi le dire
comme ça
madame Vidal pour répondre à votre
question sur la nécessité d'une
coordination et d'un travail entre les
professionnels de santé notamment entre
les médecins et les professions
d'infirmières je crois que une partie de
la réponse va venir de de l'accord qui a
été signé mercredi dernier et que ce
sujet j'allais dire de transfert ou de
partage de compétences entre les
professionnels c'est une des réponses au
temps médical qui sera dégagée et c'est
ce que nous sommes vous êtes en train de
construire mais que bien sûr les
infirmiers comme les autres professions
auront toutes leurs parts à prendre et
c'est ce vers quoi nous travaillons avec
toutes les professions médicales sur le
sujet de
les victimes de la dépakine
vous l'avez justement dit c'est un sujet
sur lequel madame levégy c'était
complètement investi lors de la dernière
mandature vous avez eu raison de
rappeler que la crise sanitaire ne
permettait pas n'a pas permis de
renforcer et de réduire le de trois mois
un mois le délai d'instruction
néanmoins si vous avez noté une baisse
des crédits c'est parce que en fait ces
crédits se font j'allais dire au fil de
l'eau et que ils prennent en compte la
gestion des dossiers au fil de l'eau
et Madame Théveneau sur la culture de la
prévention nous nous rejoignons je vais
le redire que la prévention est un enjeu
majeur de santé publique
et que l'enjeu de la communication et
tout aussi important et je vais redonner
exemple de la prévention faite autour du
tabac et que la communication du mois
sans tabac est sans doute une des belles
réussites et c'est ce vers quoi nous
devons tondre mais aussi comme l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure notre collègue
Isaac Sybille
l'enjeu d'une unification des promoteurs
de la promotion et sans doute et de la
communication et sans doute aussi en
termes de lisibilité un enjeu majeur
voilà madame la Présidente très
brièvement des réponses apportées aux
questions merci bien Madame la Ministre
pour toutes ces réponses très claires et
très concises finalement bravo merci
bien
pardon madame la députée
que c'est un enjeu important sur un
phénomène qui inquiète beaucoup
d'acteurs et que notamment tout son doit
se mettre et notamment les CJ mais aussi
plein d'acteurs autres que les
professionnels de santé doivent
s'inquiéter de ce sujet qui concerne une
partie de notre jeunesse merci madame la
ministre pour cette dernière réponse et
je vous dis donc à bientôt merci